hello everybody
what's going on
welcome back to the corridor digital
podcast it's episode 180.
man coming up on that 200 number and uh
today we've got some very special guests
we've got Jonah Kaplan
back at it good to see you all
Griffin Thorne what's up everybody
otherwise known as knife
and of course Jordan Coleman everybody
hi guys hello so
um so we're kicking it off we've been
talking about uh you know different
topics that have come up and uh one
thing people have asked us about and
that we wanted to chat about today is
this whole uh writers slash sag-aftra
strike that's going on now as many of
you know
um we are not uh union members at at
Corridor in terms of the company itself
because we don't participate in the
traditional TV and film World
um which is the main reason but as so we
won't we won't be talking about this
from like our area of expertise we'll be
talking about it from our experience and
and what we see and particularly with
Jordan being a member of sag-aftra kind
of what her experience has been
uh what she's heard from the guilds what
the main you know sort of points of
contention have been over and that sort
of thing um but an interesting thing as
these sort of Worlds have begun to
collide the digital and the traditional
we've always been on the digital side
you know as we've grown up but there's
as they Collide they start to blend
together and I think that's kind of
where this strike
starts to originate uh
Jordan we were just talking about this a
little bit ago but it seems like the the
main points of contention are coming
well you know first and foremost from
this this area of being hey everything's
moving to streaming
and and
what what what in our agreement you know
and starting with the writers what in
our agreement
with the studios has changed
given that the model for monetization of
these properties that we're writing
is no longer really being primarily
distributed in this place is that would
you say that that's kind of the gist of
the first argument Jordan or do I have
it yeah yeah it's interesting like this
whole strike is like it started with the
writer's Guild obviously and they're
basically like man our workload hasn't
decreased at all but um it's actually
increasing you have these streaming
platforms
just like ripping off all of these
writers putting all this time and it's
like you know crazy hours
um and then they they don't want to pay
any more for for streaming and writers
are and what dealing with like we were
talking about before like you have
inflation happening and they're
basically trying to pay writers and
actors the same amount that they were
paying them four years ago and that's
like with any job like even here at
Corridor you would expect
something to go up whether it's 25 cents
whether whatever it's something you know
so the fact that we're dealing with it
and
so before we yeah before we get into
some of the like reasons of you know
what where we're at and what can be done
about it let's just lay out at least
Jordan again we're not speaking about
this from a position of like Union
representation or expertise or something
you know this is again we're not
directly involved but Jordan just being
a sag after member like what have they
told what is the guild sort of presented
to you and the other members as like hey
guys this is why we're doing this and
this is why we want to join the strike
and this is why it's important for you
what have they said to you yeah I mean
so basically the president of sag um
Fran as many known from the nanny the
nanny of course yeah everyone's favorite
Nanny yeah Mr Sheffield
um she was just she was done you know
they were trying to make these contracts
with amp TP and they were just kind of
getting like bullshitted around and
finally they're like like that's been
too many years of not receiving the pay
that our members should be receiving
considering inflation considering new
advances in technology considering Ai
and they were they gave them multiple
chances to come back with a contract
that was just I mean reasonable we're
just we're asking for reasonable things
and they didn't so they're like sorry to
do this it's been over 40 years since
you know both unions have been under a
strike like this but
so so what when you say that what are
some of the did they give did they get
into that with you as like an individual
member like hey this is particularly
what we want to do this is like what we
want to set day rates at did they get
into that menu show or is it all kind of
top level yeah no you know that's the
cool thing about uh sag is they're very
upfront you know you have like low
budget media you have regular sag media
if I go to do a short film all of that
have different day rates and
meal pensions and Grace you know stuff
and all of that and um what a background
actor daily rate would be getting paid
and so all of that is completely laid
out they've been very upfront they share
the documents they showed what they
presented the amptp they showed what
like the ampt counter offers were and
it's just it's absolutely so for those
who don't know that's the American movie
producers and movie and television
producers of America
yeah and one of the the biggest things
that everyone was super upset about was
the fact that they tried to tell stag
that for background people
if we will scan them once they will work
one day and then forever we can use
their likeness and their body using AI
so essentially what would be a career in
acting
has turned into one day right yeah that
was a obviously that's the point that's
gotten the most news attention now to
clarify that a little bit it wasn't in
perpetuity for all projects it was in
perpetuity for the particular project
but
I think the point is still relevant if
you're on it's like one day on a set of
the first
filming of Star Wars
then now literally if if you were on the
first day on the first set of that
production in 1977
still today you know with everything in
every different direction that that IP
has expanded
you would still be
they would still be able to use your
name and likeness as part of that and I
think that's that's the bigger point is
it's like yeah you might not think one
project is that big of a deal
but it is and it can be and then also
not only that but one of the ways that a
lot of people start is through
background work and so you know you're
effectively giving away your name and
likeness to all these different
properties makes it harder to
well what does it make it harder to do
Jordan I mean it makes it harder to
establish yourself and well yeah I mean
consider the resume that's how I got
into acting was doing heavy heavy
background work it really would have
sucked for one to not be able to go back
on these sets again and network and meet
people because that's how I then became
a PA and then that's how I met other
people on set and also it I mean funny
how they're not scanning Pas yet they
haven't gotten to that but
yeah and also like um in the Guild in
order to get health care you have to
make twenty six thousand dollars a year
your actors
and the residuals aren't there because
streaming then how are these people
supposed to have health care and just
make living
living wages yeah so it's my
understanding a lot of the like
current deal that they're now in the
process of negotiating renegotiating or
negotiating a new but the previous deal
was still based on this very
uh traditional model of theatrical
releases especially for the writers
theatrical releases and television
distribution
but as we saw with kovid
things moved
yeah you know things you had sort of a
jump in progression towards digital and
streaming on demand
so there is an interesting question that
comes up with that
like it I do feel like a lot of the a
lot of the um things that happened
during
during covid
pushed people towards streaming
now the question is
well I mean do you think it's settled
enough as like a medium streaming as a
medium to really be able to
like say hey okay let's let's now make
Union deals based upon where this
industry has settled
because things moved really fast over
the last five years we had you know you
had this everyone knew streaming was
coming but then boom covet happened and
it accelerated it by like five years
into the future in the course of like 18
months right now of course this is kind
of what stirred on the writers strike in
the first place is they weren't getting
the deals the deal that they had
previously was no longer equitable
under the new sort of strata of the way
that things are being produced and
distributed right so I mean
have things settled out in reality
though or are they still
because that's all this is based on you
know you spend all this time you go on
strike you spend six months on strike or
whatever it might be just to get a new
agreement in place
if the entire economics of it changes
again in six months
or in six years is it gonna be is it
gonna be worth the time to do this now
I mean considering I feel like I don't
know how to speak on like the writer's
behalf yeah but it seems like they're
pretty fed up it seems like what they
have been dealing with it's just like
it's not enough money to like compared
to the demand for what they're doing and
for the people and obviously like the
shows are just not the shows without the
writers and I'm honestly like I'm not
upset about the strike like I know for a
fact I'm in a great Union and at the end
we're gonna be we're gonna have good
deals like I truly believe that
everyone's gonna come out a little
happier and I think the ultimate reason
for the strike is just greed because the
money is there
so agreed on Greed on Whose part
I am
ATM PT I can never produce letters yeah
yeah you think that's you think that's
what this comes down to
I mean it always comes down to like
Jimmy wants to give them more money or
not that's
basically what it is it's an interesting
question it is it's a legitimately
interesting question because like there
are economics to it yeah yeah
you know and and and I think the movie
we saw this coming for a while but the
movie industry is undergoing
and the television industry for that
matter is undergoing what the music
industry went through
about 15 years ago 10 15 years ago
I mean we saw this rapid decline of the
previous economic structure
upon which music was distributed which
was you make an album
you sell the album and you go on tour
that was that's that was the model yeah
now that model still
has a place
but
it's now you know much more like okay
well
you're streaming on digital platforms
you know there's been all this
disruption over like how much Spotify
pays and whether that's fair and all
that conversation and then
um and I feel like there's a similar
thing if if it's not exactly the same
it's definitely mirrored I think yeah
with that and it's interesting like I
feel like actors
we're used to not getting paid
like man trying to get a role is like
it's insane but the writers like it's
it's crazy to see people who are making
you know a lot of money considering
compared to like some other people and
then all of a sudden they're like hey
this it's still if this isn't right
they're they're cutting like their
revenue Source just off because they
feel so cheated and and how much they
know that they should be making versus
how much that they are that's the part
when it comes like to actors versus the
writers
how much they're losing I mean every day
because you're talking about writers
that were signed to a show now as you'd
mentioned a lot of this is coming from
just the the amount of things that are
being asked to be produced right like
that I mean we've all seen how much
content is being put out on platforms
like Netflix now yeah it's
I can't even
the percentage of
just you can't pay someone what you're
getting paid four years ago as well on
top of like streaming now becoming a
thing and them not really wanting to
share how much revenue is actually
coming from streaming
so there's that's a big problem yeah and
honestly that would make it easier if I
was in their position I would share all
that because it makes it easier to find
an equitable deal but you know if you
don't want an equitable deal then maybe
you don't want to share it
um but it does make it easier if it's
like hey look this is how much we
actually make from this then
you know
maybe that maybe that's easier but I I I
don't know do you feel like there is
enough I mean in Jonah Griffin you know
I'd love to hear your thoughts on this
too but you guys feel like there's
enough consideration being taken for
like what the current and existing
economics of
like film and movies and TV shows are
because the old models they're just not
the same I mean you have your outliers
of course you have your Blockbusters
you've got your
you know your Barbies or whatever it
might be that that you know there's
still bangers at the box office it's
like you know they come in with the big
numbers and that's
that's still the traditional model and
that still works for those very few
films but again you can't look at the
industry and look at okay what are the
outlier five percent
projects that still fit the old model
you got to look what are 95 of projects
being done now and 95 of projects that
are being done now are being written and
produced and they're going straight to a
streaming platform
that's the reality
so do those do those economics
support what people are actually asking
for
that's what I'm wondering I I think and
I'm not an economist and I'm also not
working these Studios but
looking at it in the way that it's
happened I do think that the growth into
the streaming model
from an economic standpoint like the the
like the rabbit's kind of out of the hat
at this point but like it does not
sustain the traditional
filmmaking business model which is like
why the writers and directors are so or
writers and and actors are so upset
because we had a system that worked
right yeah it wasn't great you know
there were flaws in it but it's like
residuals work because of Television you
know all this stuff kind of had a system
and it's you know it was all these these
Giants reacting to Netflix
um who who by the way was a tech startup
right like that Netflix is was looked at
Wall Street by Wall Street as a as a
tech startup and so they could operate
on loss for a really long time that's
how it was pitched for a really long
time if you look at the numbers they
weren't ever profitable they were
operating on loss
um but that's like how you make a
startup and then all these yeah during
the pandemic and all this stuff you get
all these streamers uh large Studios
adopting that model and well Hollywood
you're supposed to make money
you can't make money with this model in
the first couple years Netflix is just
starting to do it right but suddenly
were all of Hollywood got flipped into
this Tech Pro startup model and the
market stopped liking it also well yeah
it was I mean it was going to happen and
I think everyone knew it was going to
happen I mean Disney was working on
Disney Plus
for
like five years before they actually
rolled it out and then they rolled it
out in 2017.
yeah I think oh yeah so it it was around
before the pandemic but obviously that
accelerated things the
the thing of the thing that I is is
always interesting and the thing that's
the most difficult to figure out anytime
you have one of these strikes
is I feel like most of the time it's
based on a change of economics
and
people are used to
getting paid a certain amount they're
used to things working in a certain way
and then the economics change
and
I I would be honestly curious whether or
not the producers could give a better
deal
based on the new economics because
everybody knows streaming is not as
profitable as a pain is asking people to
pay you 18.50 at the door
of a of a movie theater right now movie
theaters what are the residuals you get
from syndicated television yeah or that
yeah
yeah I do I do think that what you're
getting at is is super valid like
everyone keeps saying that like oh
there's Deep Pockets like Bob Iger gets
paid X Y and Z it's like dude we're
talking about an industry right and
they're already hemorrhaging money yeah
Bob Iger could probably take a pay cut
great but like we're talking about like
the
not just like one year or one show we're
talking about hundreds of thousands of
shows in years and years and years it's
like how are we going to make a system
that works and I think all the studios
are already scared because it's not
working so yeah so people understand
more more context of what's really like
the the historical moment that we're
currently in I mean this is similar to
like in terms of and the entertainment
industry this is like when World War One
happened this is like this is the end of
feudalism like feudalism existed for
1500 years and then World War One
happened and then World War II had to
happen to like fully
clean things out but that's you look at
the entertainment industry
films and movie theatrical movie
distribution has been around
for a hundred and
120 130 years in some places and the
model has not changed that much when you
look at it
as at its core it's like the combustion
engine it's like you were still the core
model at least like you know TV is a
little bit different but the core model
of film was you make the thing you put
it behind a paywall people pay you money
to get into the room to see it and then
you move on to the next town
now it got a lot more complex and it
grew and it expanded but the core model
has been exactly the same now
the core model is okay
it's the same idea you put it behind a
paywall people have to pay to see it but
the scale
it's like way the scale is way different
than it ever was before
yeah it's like it's like sneaking into
an AMC with one ticket and watching
everything in the theater yeah exactly
yeah for a month for a month yeah
and like I mean I mean think about that
people like you look at the core
economics of it
it was no question to pay 15 17 even 20
dollars to get into a movie theater
would you do you even pay that for like
your favorite streaming platform
what's your favorite streaming platform
you know do you pay
do you pay twenty dollars a month to get
that student platform it's at 18 and
when they find out that my parents are
also on it I think they're gonna charge
me an extra they're gonna yeah they're
gonna double it or whatever they're
gonna charge you an extra five at least
Netflix is definitely the highest but
they have like the most they have a lot
of deals out there when you talk about
like Adam Sandler so that's that's my
that's my like
that's the main point that I want to try
to like contextualize here
I I don't know the minutia of you know
exactly what they're fighting about but
if you just look at the numbers
people used to pay
let's call it 17 bucks to go to a film
now you're lucky if you can get somebody
to pay that for one month to have access
to your entire platform
everything on it
how can the economics match up under
those circumstances
how can you say you know what writers
you're right we'll pay you we'll pay you
what you need we'll pay you what you pay
you more
numbers well exactly well that's what
they should do we can all be on the same
page and help each other
exactly
um
content this is where you start this is
where you start to get into the question
of like well if they are withholding
that type of information then yeah why
you know what what exactly do they not
want people to see and that that that's
I think that's a great Point Jordan like
why wouldn't they just
say that if they couldn't afford it why
wouldn't they just say it
yeah
yeah there's all these like little other
things like dealing with like sad stuff
that they want to be better like there's
I don't know I know you guys don't
really see my day-to-day life but
sometimes like I'll get an audition and
then it'll be like a six page audition
and they want it due in like a day and a
half yeah like that and it's like oh
well because well inflation and rent is
so high like I have a job I have
multiple jobs I bet okay cool let me
push out this audition and then they're
like it'll be 8 P.M I'm like oh tomorrow
at 2 p.m you have an in-person audition
it's like what like how are you guys
expecting us and so that's another thing
in the agreement is not forcing actors
especially for like low budget media to
have to memorize five to ten pages of
content to turn around for you just to
pay us like a day rate of 200 when we do
get on set it's like you get this it's
just they're wanting to a lot out of
people and then not paying them well so
I mean anybody who's ever gone to
Hollywood and done anything the first
thing that you see
and this is more for people who haven't
seen this but the first thing you see is
how impossible it is to be an actor or
actress like it's it's it's almost
impossible because that's exactly what
you're supposed to do you're supposed to
memorize six pages of something the next
day and show up at 2 p.m
across town it takes you an hour and a
half to get there and an hour 45 to get
back because you hit Rush Hour which
kind of only slows down momentarily
between noon and two and then picks up
again
so four hours of your day to go to an
audition to try to get a part that's
going to pay you
you know a couple hundred bucks if
you're lucky so it's like you have
everyone that's a bartender or server
maybe but everything's so sporadic find
a job that's not gonna be like just fire
you because it's the last minute all of
these last minute things that they're
just requesting requesting requesting
right just just to not book you by the
way yes it's kind of the background
actor conversation too man where it's
like you get in those rooms with those
auditions
um and you get to meet casting agents
and you get to get get notes back from
people right and it's like with the
model of doing
um this the digital submissions it's
like you know you just have your laptop
you're just staring yourself in the
mirror not only that if you really look
at it too it's economically trapping
people because the quality of your
audition is now
dependent on the quality of your
microphone in your internet connection
and your webcam and it's like you can
say oh performance is performance but
it's like yeah but right there's like
all these barriers separating you from
the business now and it's just like why
even be in Hollywood if you're gonna if
you're gonna be in you know because we
love it
I'm literally in a class to be able to
audition like learn how to audition and
Captivate the casting director producer
on camera like there's this whole
technique and because you know you're no
longer going into a room anymore you're
no longer immutable and I used to book a
lot like I was in commercials before I
started working here at quarter and I
would I would Buck constantly because
they fill your presence and it's just a
whole different
um type of thing but now it's like you
have these casting directors sending out
auditions to like 300 people and they're
literally just clicking through people
they're not even watching what you just
spent three days like working on so can
any of this be avoided truly because you
know what what drives this ultimately
what drives this is cons the consumer
yeah like of course if you give the
consumer an option to pay 17.50 to get
access to the entire Netflix library for
a month or to pay 17.50 to see one thing
one time that's on Netflix of course
they're gonna pick the thing that has
more value this is how we got Amazon
this is this is how we got here so you
if if if that is driving down the value
of what the industry can take in in
terms of a gross level of money
what do you do
what do you do what do you do Griffin
what do we do
I'm no expert I'm not a union actor
um you're wait you're not a union actor
you're a union sarcastic I'm a I'm a
union knife guy
he makes the props I mean we
just just as as an average ordinary guy
type dude you know we we kind of glossed
over the whole like Bob Iger makes x
amount of money and it's it's awfully
hard to not look at you know all of the
things that go into this situation and
into you know revenue streams and
economics and say well
these shareholders and these Executives
still are able to bring in triple digit
million dollar salaries and
there isn't money for cost of living
raises sure but I think the point that
Jonah was making I think I was making it
too is just simply even if you got rid
of those things it wouldn't
get rid of it fine like I again I'm not
the kind of guy who's gonna sit here and
defend a CEO who gets paid three times
300 times their their lowest paid
employee like I'm not
I think there's there's a reasonable
level at which
you know the the head of an organization
should be paid with respect to their
lowest paid person that makes sense but
I'm not going to defend that I'm just
saying like doing that doesn't change
the economics
of the industry
yeah it it may like alleviate some of
the pressure points and say Hey you know
you guys are getting paid too much
you can tone it down you don't need to
give a nine Cent per share dividend or
whatever it might be every quarter you
don't need to do all that
you can take the money you can put it
back into the industry you can put it
back into production you can put it back
into the pockets of the people that are
actually making the stuff for you which
by the way is the same gripe that I have
about digital media platforms they pay
us Pennies on the dollar to make
basically for them free content which is
another in just absolutely insane
thing when you think about like all the
minutes that get put onto YouTube Every
Day YouTube is not go like they're not
buying it
they're saying they're saying it will
pay you if you uh make it uh yeah yeah
we'll pay you yeah well they're counting
it over here you know what do they need
yeah yeah here you go yeah
but anyways that's another another we'll
get into that on another day
um but anyway I don't think it changes
the economics and that's I think
the the real son of a [__] of it it's
like I don't think we're gonna Place
economically where we where the industry
is the same
as it was
prior to this sort of digital era and
that's I think what this whole
conversation is about trying to figure
that out
I I had this really dark thought the
other day when I was talking to a buddy
of mine about this where like which
streaming services are doing all right
and I don't obviously we don't have the
figures but it's like you look at like a
company like apple that has really some
really good original content and it's
like if you look at the way that they're
doing it or like Amazon
that is only part of what they're doing
right you have Amazon which is like
Amazon and it does music and web hosting
and it does deliveries and then you have
apple who's does user devices wait I
thought Amazon sold online books and
books for that matter and that's that's
how they started by the way but a lot of
people out of someone's uh you know out
of someone's garage but like I think the
darkest future man of this and who knows
maybe we'll look back in this in five
years and I'll be really sad because I
was right I I almost think we might lose
some of the majors and they'll kind of
collapse into like older style Hollywood
into like one or two and we're probably
gonna have like a lot more
streamers that are not predominantly
streamers like it'll be like
Walmart
and like they had their Walmart and then
they have like Walmart streaming and
there's like all the biggest kind of
like corporations like Monopoly are
gonna use the fact that they have a
diversity of of God that's really that's
really a gross dystopia you're right
though but dude it's like it's what
Apple's doing right now it's what
Amazon's doing right now and they're
doing okay and it's like
that is the darkest future here is that
we lose old the lose the a lot of what
old Hollywood is and we turn into a
streaming model that only works because
it is part of a larger company that does
not need its profits to be fulfilled by
only a cinematic audience right I don't
want that to happen they just get really
narrow with their I mean you you could
easily extrapolate the current industry
to this very quickly I mean there's
there's certain houses like Blum House
that only do a certain type of film
because they know that's the thing that
works for them so then you'll get like
Walmart streaming and you know whatever
it might be that Gypsy streaming yeah
yeah it's like oh are you what kind of
theme is that is that like a
coming-of-age story or were you gonna
license that to Pepsi yeah you know yeah
and then blumhouse is gonna get work you
know these small shops like I think the
all these smaller companies are actually
still gonna exist and they're just
they're not gonna be licensing to
traditionals anymore it's probably a
good attention I don't want this to be
true I I feel like it we're we might
already be there if not well on the way
because I mean if you even look at like
how many
um Studios how many networks how many
what have you are owned by Viacom alone
yeah or you know looking at the the
recent notorious HBO
Discovery merger and even if you look at
other Industries and
just yeah I mean the whole of the whole
of Television is what five companies
yeah I mean look at food production
Global food production there's like
six conglomerates that make every
product I mean so there are four there
are four companies in the united not to
go on too much of a tangent here about
meat packing but just just to just to
back up your point there are four
companies
uh Tyson Smithfield uh one and two two
others uh that do 80 percent of all
meat packaging in this country
eighty percent four companies and that's
why it's very very difficult to make a
living as a as a small farmer because
you can't take your product to a meat
packing plant that will support your
scale because what they've done is
they've continued to make more
regulation
to sort of push out people who cannot do
it at that scale
and so you have to take like in order if
you're going to process meat and sell it
to somebody else you have to like take
it to a FDA approved facility and the
only ones that'll take you are like the
few Mom and Pops that are still around
and all the other ones have gone just to
hey we just take care of the big boys
they bring in their hundred head every
week and we just boom boom boom and it's
big business for us and it works for
them but we don't we can't we literally
cannot accommodate anybody else because
of our model and I think that's
yeah that's kind of we're seeing that
happening in a lot of different places
Griffin
yeah so Jonah I think
you know it's already here let the let
the dark thoughts win dude wow that's
very depressing I just really wanted
someone to tell me I was being crazy I
was like looking around the room like yo
tell me I'm wrong guys
things keep changing so fast I don't
know I would like to go back to cable
television personally that's the thing
is I wouldn't actually I don't know yeah
I'd like to go back to a model where
like you have to see a movie in a
theater
I already I don't know I do that I like
I buy the AMC pass and I go like one to
two times a week but that's okay dude
that's also trying to be competitive for
streaming that only exists because
they're afraid no I also say I want to
go back to cable because I would benefit
as an actress in The Guild that's why
because I love I love being able to just
buy a movie on YouTube or on Amazon and
just watch it
it's like the stupidest easiest thing in
the world and this is my consumer side
speaking what is the with cable that
with the cable package you can also do
that with movies within it's a paper not
pay-per-view but On Demand right isn't
that like all with on cable as well so
it's like I feel like you can watch
whatever you want like what do you mean
by cable
well I don't know every time I'm at a
family's house
I don't think any of us in here I don't
know but when you are scrolling through
channels there's like the on-demand
channels that you can like pause you can
like record you can like get movies yeah
that's like that's like a certain
subsection of your overall package
though that you would purchase from say
DirecTV or your cable provider not a bad
model
no but again meant to be competitive
with video on demand yeah and the video
on demand model is just so
easy for consumers I know it's like if
you know that you can watch this is
here's a little here's a little dark
secret about me okay I've been watching
through the Fast and Furious franchise
since we did since we did that uh Fast
and Furious whatever that crew video
and uh one thing I do is it's like oh I
got an hour and a half okay go to the
next one it's 3.79 to watch it in 4k
I punch in my little password
and boom literally 30 seconds later
I paid 3.79 I'm watching this movie for
the next hour and a half it's a rental
obviously you don't own it but you don't
own it anyway when you buy it on the
platform
and then
that I mean that's that's just like
that's what everyone does with the model
you know that's how everyone like to
have it that convenient
and accessible
yeah you're still paying for it so I
just
yeah yeah it's it's a question of if we
want to keep it like this if we want it
to feel like this and not go into dark
dystopian Pepsi future I think we need
to be cool sorry to call them out never
gonna get a job at Pepsi now
you'll never work in this town
um
but like we either need to be okay with
less content
right yeah right
um or more advertising well that's an
interesting thing to the two things that
are make if there's more advertising
then they can they can sell more as they
can make more money
they can pay everyone more fairly go
ahead
Hulu I'm sorry Hulu this is not
um a personal attack but I have the base
free Hulu subscription and they've
started putting ads when you pause yep
you're like you'll hit pause and it'll
just be like new from Pepsi friggins
Pepsi's taken up that sounds awesome in
this episode
just give me give me less stuff yeah if
I had to choose there's there's too much
stuff to watch I can't watch even a
quarter of it if I tried to watch all of
it yeah we don't need Jonah I think yeah
I think you're making a great point
there which is absolutely
you you everybody
agrees
you don't watch everything that's on
Netflix you don't watch everything
that's on Amazon you don't buy
everything that's in Walmart when you go
into Walmart like you have your
particulars now this is where
I don't I don't know I I'm very hesitant
to say like hey the government should
come in with antitrust and like break
some of this up because I I know how bad
they are at their job and it makes me
very hesitant to say that but if there
was one thing where you know something
might serve the consumer
it would be hey maybe
not everything is on Amazon in the exact
same place
and I and I don't just mean that in
terms of movies I mean that in terms of
like that company is just too goddamn
big
like it it is let's be like it's take
they're killing every mom and pop
they're killing every manufacturing
they're killing every they're doing this
to the entertainment industry as well
they're driving down the cost of what
they can generate so that drives down
the cost of what can be paid which puts
the writers and the actors on strike
yeah it's like the whole thing is part
of this and again this is just one like
sliver of the overall thing that's been
happening for the last you know 40 50
years which is this sort of trend toward
globalization
and we're seeing and everyone's like oh
well globalization's good it makes
things cheaper it makes things more
available but also you're seeing the
other side of it now which is when it
goes too far it turns everything into a
terrible horrible dystopian future where
Pepsi is now serving you rom-coms
so you're essentially pitching that the
solution is to tell these larger
corporations that are
to basically do like yeah an Anti-Trust
thing and it's not it's not on like
discovery
or like uh
I don't think that it's necessarily like
a a government solution that you can
just again Everyone likes to go well if
we just got in there and took one big
swing I think it's like you know like
the bludgeoning you know tool it's it's
more it's more about if if people would
be willing to pay more for less but the
less is more valuable to them
that's the thing and I think we do see
that with the corridor digital platform
that is a tiny I think Silver Lining at
least in my life that I've seen where
people pay us 3.99 and yeah is it
like relative to what you get for Disney
plus is is the 399
like the same cost per what you purchase
no
no it's not you're paying more per
minute and you're paying more for it but
you're paying for what you want and
we're giving it directly to you
and the cycle goes around and round and
round
and that has more value
to the person
than it does to say hey pay four times
that and get access to everything that's
on Netflix because you that that doesn't
give you anything in here you know it's
like you're not getting that value from
that purchase you're getting like
the Bounty of
one penny Goods that
you know they're trying to stuff as many
one penny widgets as they can inside the
box and just be like here just take this
leave us alone
it's super random but there's this
commercial I keep hearing it's an it's
an app they want you to pay for the app
and that app will help you keep track of
all of the apps that you have that
you're paying subscribers I love that ad
so much but I'm like oh my God me to do
what it's like it's like an app it's a
rocket money yeah it's Those ads that
are like do you spend too much time on
your phone here's this app to help you
spend a lot less time on your phone
how do you get rid of your subscriptions
I'm like this is yeah dude
are are finally realizing this though
like we we've I think literally after
covid I do think that I do think that
there is hope for the future because I
think people turn to corner with respect
to some of this [__] some of these
stupid games where it's like get the app
to use less apps it's like
but no but seriously like before but
like eight years ago 10 years ago that
would have been
that would have been I don't know people
wouldn't have thought twice about they
would have do you have do you have aptly
you know and they'd like take the vowels
out of it and then like put the cross
logo and you know make it some
sans-serif font with like some pastel
color and you're just like with a white
background you just like shoot me you
know I don't need another one of these
yeah and and this is exactly the way
that rock and roll finally died because
people saw in the 1980s on ski on on
Sunset Strip how it got it went from Van
Halen and Guns and Roses to just
everybody repeating the exact same
[__] thing to make it
to make money basically and all the art
of it and all the Artistry and all the
things that came from it that people
loved about it
were a carcass of what they were and I
think that there is a little bit of that
happening now finally where people are
realizing hey you can't get everything
from a streaming service can't get
everything from a phone yeah and like
what you really want to pay for is it
like if I could sell you
a hundred of your favorite of your
favorite movies and shows for like 15
bucks
you would buy it because those are all
your favorite things in one place
you'd pay more for it because it has
more value and again it comes down to
this value versus quantity thing and I
think that's the ultimate like decision
that people make on the consumption
level that affects
you know things like what's happening
with the writers and and actors strike
you know what those one cool thing about
the streaming platform though for actors
especially it's like
well okay so if like writers now you're
able to kind of get a little more
creative and you can have a show that's
like we don't know about it but there's
such low risk of putting it onto
whoever's streaming platform and so now
you get someone that got to put put it
on 2B and see what happens yeah and it's
like boom okay cool a Creator just got
to put out something and then like
there's up and coming actors and
actresses that now get uh shitty right
but work because okay they didn't get
onto the big Blockbuster film but now
they get to do that so it's like that is
the one like kind of argument I would
have with streaming is the I mean
Limited
unlimited possibilities of being able to
to put stuff on there and it's just like
no one's going to unsubscribe from
Netflix because a shitty show got put on
there
you know no yeah it's almost it's almost
like you're saying Jordan you might
unsubscribe if a thousand of them get
put on there though because honestly it
clogs up your experience but but what if
you have a small amount of shows right
you're saying quality over quantity but
then it's like well if you have this
impression you're like this is the
perfect streaming service it's been
built for me and there's not too much
stuff but like everything is a banger
then the percentage if something you
disagree with is put on it the
percentage of how much you care and how
much that affects you is a lot higher
yes no totally yeah yeah you know but
this is so this is where AI comes in
and I want to bring this up anyway
because it leads into part of the
writer's strike arguments but this is
also where AI comes into this
I'll go on yeah yeah
the in regards to like the low risk
things being put on streaming I think
a potentially strong argument for the
like more curated higher value approach
to you know media is if you look at the
BBC and what they had done with their
cable programming for years was they
would take similar risks on interesting
new television shows by giving them like
a two or four episode season they would
you know they wouldn't just
invest less time into
or they would give it less time and then
you didn't have like you know you opened
up a streaming service and there's 40
bajillion
ugly derivative adult animated shows or
reality shows or forgettable crime drops
right you know
yeah that would be really interesting to
see it's something we talk about you
know in this little pulling the curtain
back on what we're doing at Corridor but
as we've talked about this Jake like we
like the idea that
what we want to do with the website is
something where it's not yeah it's not
like seasons of Television but it's like
quality ideas and we get to test those
out
um and you know I think
that business model is smart and you get
some really inventive ideas that way
we're going to be doing that this fall
with you Jonah yeah that's the idea and
so yeah what you're saying is really
excited to me exciting to me because
it's like if we can take the BBC model
and attempt that on on a small streaming
service that people just care to be
there yeah
um I think that is a viable Way Forward
I do just get concerned that like with
what you're saying Jake too and you know
this smaller smaller streamers with
everything you want so that so imagine
that happens right and then you have
like you know 80 to 100 or maybe
thousands of these small little ones
like white cord or digital right you
know and you're like wow finally we did
it they're all in control of themselves
and they're self-sufficient and then
some [__] it's gonna come in and
be like wait a minute what if we just
bought them all what if you had an app
what if you had an app where you could
watch
that's how this whole system works
though it's it's like it it but when the
see that when the big boys buy too many
of those little boys
eventually they're they get so
crusted up with you know the model
having to work in the most precise way
because again all they care about is how
much money they can extract out of it
and so because like again yeah I don't I
don't understand quite fully the
corporate chain mentality I I think
there's a there's a
there's a little bit of a
what's the right word
like I don't know if psychopath is the
right word but like you got to be a
little crazy like just a little bit to
be like you know what all these things
will be mine
you know it's like hmm I don't trust I
don't know if I quite trust this person
um but at the same time I see why it
gets done because it's like well we you
know the other argument the more Humane
argument is well we have a good business
model and these people were trying to do
the same thing that we were trying to do
we just did it a little bit better so we
bought them and turned them into us you
know that's more like the Genghis Khan
model where it's like you become my
General Sir once I take you over
um but anyways yeah I digress
that's I I love that exam I love Genghis
Khan as an example of a not crazy
it absolutely was but but my point is
for sure he wouldn't just kill his
enemies outright
he would he would say this is what we're
doing and this is why you should come
and follow me and why my model is better
and why you will be better under my
model
but he was still CR I mean he's what
he's like the you know the ancient
ancestor of like half of the world but
other than that you know the point the
point is very good it absolutely now I'm
just imagining like like laying out the
the compensation
and if you don't like it I'll cut your
head off
you see like around five years stock
options
oh man it'll give you an extra horse
yeah if you stick around that fifth year
you get an extra horse
but yeah man I mean we're at an
interesting time
um I do think we haven't really touched
the surface of like the whole AI
concerns you know
um I do feel like a lot of those are
blowing a little out of proportion I
mean obviously there was the one with
the Screen Actors Guild about being able
to scan you and then have you be a part
of that production forever there was
also some concern about the use of AI
with respect to the writer's Guild where
they were saying hey guys they're going
to have ai come up with drafts and then
have
writers basically punch up and refine
those drafts as it were
to me
that use is a lot more viable than
obviously this let's scan your body and
own you forever thing
[Music]
um because you would think that it would
lead to more uh Stories being told
but again one thing Nico and I were
talking about with respect to these
strikes is when you look at it only from
the lens that there's so many
distribution Outlets then the idea of
using AI to help write more stories to
pay less writers on a particular project
become sounds like a bad thing when you
only have a limited number of outlets
and so this is again Jonah going back to
what you were saying which is like well
maybe there's going to be more outlets
in the future
I don't know but God make it stop I know
I just I hope I'm not spilling the tea
here to the studios but like they know
like Unreal Engine exists with
metahumans like they don't need to scan
anyone like I mean they know right like
that's what I'm sorry and I just got
really fixated on that one point man but
it's like when they've been talking
about the scanning thing I just keep
thinking over and over again I'm like
but then think about it but then that
goes into how now the effects artists
want to like become unionized because
it's like producers they still don't
know how to work on real like that'd be
like me being like well I can just go
make a metal human I can't make [__] and
I don't know how to work unreal so they
would still have to pay people
rather it would be way cheaper to scan
someone and then use their likeness for
forever rather than pay someone to do
unreal every day if we talk about AI
then we're talking about the VFX
industry which is like three podcasts of
what's going on right now crazy because
we should probably we should probably
Peg that onto another one and pick up
this conversation but it is interesting
to see I think overall the point is
we're at a Crossroads I think we all
know how we got here
but I don't know if we all know where
it's gonna go and we're certainly here
because of a lot of the advancements of
digital a lot of the advancements of AI
if you can even call it that I really
hate to use that word because it is just
machine learning computer programs it's
there's nothing
Advanced and sentient about it it makes
it sound like it's sentient which I
don't really like but
um very good marketing
companies because there's a there is a
picture that surfaced of me on the
internet
um of on Rebel Moon it was a leaked
photo and I don't remember I don't
remember taking the photo now what I do
remember is being scanned for hours
that's like hundreds of cameras yeah you
know and I am in that outfit and and
everything but I I'm I'm into very very
very small part of the movie but I'm I'm
very interested just to see like am I
going to see myself in multiple parts of
this movie that would have been giving
me
more money like that would have been
another day right another say if I
didn't have like a full-time job like if
I was a working actor and I'm like oh
well a guess who didn't make the 26 000
to get health care but guess who could
have if they actually paid me every day
it's very interesting when you when you
think about it like that like how many
days you would be missing if it wasn't
for some of these technological
advancements I think that's what people
I think we're trying to set like a
precedent or like
so like sometimes the AI is getting
blown out of control but it's like about
how far will it keep going and like well
yeah some people will benefit some
people won't and when you think of like
when you move to Hollywood like what how
much money you could have made versus
like a year now because of advancements
well this is how much you're going to
make now deal with it it's just like you
know what can you do it's it's a bummer
because these tools are being turned
into the villain when it's really the
people abusing them that I feel like are
the villain it's like it sucks man
because the guy or girl or whoever who
took your model and made a photo with it
like I don't think they're a bad person
like they're trying to they've been
hired by someone and they're trying to
make a living and so they're saying well
I can do this and it'll get me money
because I am an art a working artist
working for a large studio and it's like
you know I the last thing I want people
to do in this moment when we're talking
about AI is to like like
it the concepts of like ownership and
the way that we uh attribute our
influences and all these things and this
is on top of mind because I'm writing
this video with Nico it's like you know
those things are like tool agnostic and
we need to
like pointing the fingers at someone who
is interested in like learning a tool is
like yeah someone can use it to take
your likeness and steal a day from you
but it's like let's not yell at the
person who's interested in learning we
can yell at the person who's taking work
away from people right but those are not
the same person yeah
um in the in the same tool that Corridor
will use to like tell a story like a
corporation will abuse right
is it our responsibility not to or is it
our responsibility to keep those people
accountable in the same way and so this
this is a perfect button here Jonah you
just laid it out perfectly because how
do you keep them accountable
and this is the re here's you ready for
the Shocker and the worst part about it
it's how you spend your money
that's how you keep them accountable
that's the only way because the only
thing corporates care about is money
it's the only thing they care about
that's their entire organization it goes
from hey we got a good product and we
got a good culture and we got to give
something to the people I mean we saw
this happen with Black Rifle coffee no
again no no shame against those guys I
love those guys but what happened when
they went IPO is they became about
the price of the share not about the
coffee and it's you know there's an
argument to be made on both sides but
like very strongly I saw with the
actions of the board and like the way
that the culture went like it became
stopped being about the thing that they
were doing it became about the money
and you know it's they're still I still
drink their coffee I still like those
guys like you know and all that good
stuff but like there was that shift and
and that's true for every core every
corporation that's public especially if
it's public that's true and so the only
way you hold them accountable is is how
do you spend your money
do you buy from them or not
and it's hard sometimes because you want
access to that Netflix library for
7.79 with ads or whatever it is you know
but uh that's the world we're in
what if like your cousin has an account
though and so like you kind of use his
but you don't really have to pay like
where's the line
they once tweet they once tweeted before
their whole share price debacle which
basically like
the market value of their company by a
into one third of what it was when you
know remember they had a share price of
like seven hundred and twenty dollars
and then it dropped to 200.
well they had once tweeted before that
whole debacle that sharing your password
was love
so yeah you know that's what they wanted
so there you go
well all right you know there's a
streaming service you can go to that
isn't screwing you and it's
quarterdigital.com hey
[Music]
again they got a great service it
doesn't go down and it had a great price
we're we're not you know we're not that
much different
but we are still the little guy so if
you support us over there on quarter
digital we appreciate it and uh Jordan
good luck with the strike I hope you get
your walking boots on and get out there
and get what you need
yeah I'm actually about to head to
acting class right now what a better
time than to refine your skills than
when you can't work anyways
take the time to get better
to show the world
all right y'all sharing your experiences
and your insights into this topic yeah
thank you guys for that very helpful
alrighty thanks for listening everybody
and uh we'll see on the next one
have a great day